this week many of us have been paying
tribute to the brave men and women who
secured victory and peace
in europe 77 years ago and so it's a sad
irony that we've been forced to discuss
how best to fortify our shared defenses
against the empty conceit of a 21st
century
tyrant
when europe celebrated ve day in 1945 a
victory that was of course
in those small part ensured
by the heroism of the russian people
we hoped that peace on our continent
would endure
well putin's bloodthirsty campaign
against a sovereign
nation
has put an end to that hope and we face
a new reality
but one that we face together
throughout this conflict our nordic
partners have been leading international
support not just for ukraine but also
for european security
from sending defensive weapons and
equipment to bringing together
international partners and standing
shoulder to shoulder with us in the un
uh the human rights council
the icc the international criminal court
the war in ukraine is forcing us all
to make difficult decisions
but sovereign nations must be free to
make those decisions without fear or
influence or threat of retaliation so
i'm very pleased today
with you
prime minister anderson
to sign this mutual security assurances
declaration
it's an agreement that brings our two
countries even closer together it will
allow us
to share
more intelligence bolster our military
exercises and further our joint
development of technology
the many carcasses of
russian tanks
that now litter the fields and streets
of ukraine
thanks to swedish developed and british
built end laws
certainly speak to how effective that
cooperation
can be
but most importantly
this is an agreement
that enshrines the values
that both sweden and the uk
hold dear and which we will not hesitate
to defend and as you
put it so well uh magdalena when we're
out on the lake uh we are now literally
and metaphorically
in the same way